damian lillard really aggressive early
on in dave
races to the cup and one dame able to
force the foul
the bucket big time 133 left
i'm going to take over dame working
damian lillard give me 51.
and the trailblazers get a crucial win
i've been trying to do everything i
could to keep us in the playoff race
this one was different because our
season was you know on the line
you made noise when you said like if
you're going to come out here
in the bubble you wanted to play with a
purpose take me through the mindset of
what it was to get here and be playing
at such a high level right now
i said what i meant i didn't want to
have to come here
and train and do all this stuff to come
here to play eight games and go home
and um our team is fighting for it right
now my mentality was to come here and
just show up you know compete at the
highest level
and try to have the biggest impact that
i can on winning lillard step back three
ridiculous i cannot count the number of
times we've seen lillard take over a
game
so far we've put ourselves in position
to control our own destiny
and i love our fight you know i love
that we're here to accomplish something
and everybody's committed to that
two free throws for damien lillard with
his team down by
one damien lillard comes up short
on the first attempt
[Music]
missed them both the clippers hand the
blazers a
big bubble blow he had a tough loss
against the clippers the other night we
saw what patrick beverly the antics they
they did towards the end of the game
did things go too far in your mind
from that game and what happened
afterwards going back to the beginning
like i missed two free throws at the end
of the game which is not something that
i typically would do
some failures don't happen you know i
mean i'm not above failing or coming up
short and it happened in that moment
you know teams gonna be hype about it
teams gonna talk trash but it turned
into a ton
you know to me when they started tapping
their wrists and waving way after the
fact
and then i was asked about it so when i
was asked about it i was like
shot's being fired in my direction i'm
gonna fire back facts
asking me about patrick beverly who i
sent him home before
at the
[Applause]
paul george just got sent home by me
last year in the playoffs
[Music]
and i saw that pg said you know you
could be going home this year
which is also true but that's what we're
here for to see
how that's going to play out would you
like to have a clippers up in the
playoffs i mean i'm not seeking them out
we want to get the a-spot and whoever's
in front of us right there we're just
going to be the lakers if we get the
spot that's what we're going to go in
there focus on and we're going to just
go from there i'm not
i want to play this person to that
person we don't have the luxury of doing
that you know we're trying to earn
a spot and that's all i'm focused on
this portland trailblazers team can be
dangerous you don't want to see this
team
come play off time before you got here i
was telling people like man
blazer they get in like they're going to
be a threat do you view this
team right now as a championship team i
think anything can happen
right now and i think we're capable of
doing it there's no home court
there's no fans the environment is just
different it has a different dynamic to
it because of all those things i feel
like you know we really have a chance we
just got to get in and then i think
anything goes anything can happen